[Musique]
bonsoir au soir europe où le cheval a
tout de suite patron tu es bien pressé
nounours mais jamie m'attendent ce
qu'ils vont être content au pop hip hop
hop hop hop hop hop propose aussi des
enfants vous allez être contents car
nounours va vous raconter une jolie
histoire
bonsoir le petit sait quelle histoire
que tu n'auras pas une histoire d'une
petite fille que vous aimez beaucoup
deviner
à la gauche doit et commence
la vie raconte
philippines la petite fille road gentil
qu'aucune charmante et aline j'ai
évidemment
aujourd'hui je vais des mamans à faire
de la cuisine viens avec moi dit elle sa
poupée en la prenant dans ses bras si
philippines en train dans la cuisine sa
maman était en train de préparer une à
mme abena
philippines l'aida à mélanger la farine
à pétrir la pâte à la roue et à la
mettre dans le moule mais compte elle
vit que sa maman garni c'est la tarte
avec des fringues
rêver elle se cache
derrière la porte
[Rires]
du budget du budget
bientôt le lapin blanc entre à sans
faire de bruit et se précipita sur la
tarte aux fraises qu'ils mangent à toute
entière
mais quand il voulu ressortir
la porte était fermée à clé
j'ai attrapé le lapin blanc
j'ai attrapé le napa plan et philippine
toute heureuse grillet sauté dans sa
joie du tambour
[Musique]
le lendemain matin
le long de mama temps
oui pas de nouveau but est d'apporter la
chute je n'ai pas oublié j'ai fait
exprès et je vous la raconterai une
autre fois quand vous aurait été sage
maintenant oui je vous le donne ça nous
on fait ça toute une collection allons
les enfants
[Musique]
courent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dbt tu dis tu me tiens voici le lapin
blanc pinot sur moi patron lourd allons
en route gro farseth
bonne et des enfants bonne nuit geof ont
embrassé bien fort vos parents embrasse
bien fort vos pores haut et faites de
beaux rêves
ufo de boer
[Musique]
ans